ci tenevo a voler precisare una cosa
prima di partire non mi vedete fare
horror da un po perché circa due tre
mesi fa quando ho fatto gli ultimi non
stavano andando più molto bene ci ho
visto che il pubblico non era più
interessato agli horror quindi ogni
volta che faccio un horror va male ed
essendo questo oltre che il mio hobby
anche il mio lavoro e questo non sapete
tutti devo dare priorità ai contenuti
che performano quindi io non abbandonerò
mai gli horror mi vedrete portarne di
tanto in tanto però a me piace lussi
euro mi è sempre piaciuto e non mi va
mai di abbandonarlo anzi vorrei portarlo
anche in quello che faccio adesso
di tanto in tanto quindi eccoci fine
nella parte seria ed attenti ragazzi e
benvenuti a che sono video sono fa vj
oggi siamo sud corse forest è uno dei
giochi che ho portato all'inizio proprio
del canale des è uscito nel 2019 ci ho
messo sei anni a far uscire però va bene
era una demo ai tempi ci ha messo un
sacco a farlo spero sia garino almeno su
un telefono grazie però andò vodafone
hai un medico non si capisce come uno
scrive ben chiaro comunque la trama è
che un medico ricevere la chiamata da
vodafone scrive la ricetta e prende la
macchina e va
nella foresta complimenti per sei
passato dalla fa complimenti bravo tu si
che si sveglio c'è un'ombra che si muove
chi se ne frega un c è passato qualcuno
ma che figata raga fatto veramente bene
buongiorno ragazzi questa è la foresta
maledetta no mamma mia che kakà mi sono
veramente cagato l'ho detto va bene
meno male non è che non so che ha
scritto bene ragazzo facevi meglio
restare a casa oggi ti capita qualsiasi
cosa finché non mi spunta satana davanti
io sono contento buongiorno
ma c'è un'ombra perderò sono io stupido
vedi ma che è madonna ragazzi sto gioco
era bellissimo mi ricordo perché è stato
un livido più di successo del canale
perché è uscito un certo punto il
demonio down da un secchio buongiorno
una carota a noi e nel gioco ma va all
ora
ma vedi che possa accendere e spegnere
le cose ah ok solo che non ho questo
cronaca robin filo la carota nell'anno
cosa devo fare questa carota
se però state calmi perché io non metto
a posto niente qua ecco lì dentro non
c'entra lei mai nella vita forse solo
per scampare una verifica di matematica
ma se no non c'entro buongiorno mi
servirebbe a si può entrare si può
entrare per me permesso ferma a si può
entrare solo 6 la carota va bene se
senta la carota gliela lascio lì non ho
niente la lascio qua varrà vado via ha
mai dato un braccio e con il mio quando
non faccio palestra uguale grazie molto
gentile grazie cosa me ne faccio gli sto
braccio qua
vorrei arrivare anche un altro pezzo di
corpo non può essere ma devo farlo devo
fare ok di qua devo fare parkour è
diventato un parkour questo aiuto
mamma mia
sono vivo a posto sono cascato dal sono
hai tutto ok
no problem perché nel fare per cui
faccio un po schifo posso andare posso
andare di qua perfetto ci siamo arrivati
ho preso l'altro braccio sono due
vi prego ti prego no fa è sparito
dov'è andato basta fare misti scherzi
versa la sede vi se devi rompermi le
palle vieni qua ti picchio facciamo
prima
madonna che kakà non me l'aspettavo mai
qua mi sono preso un infarto serio amico
mio ma che ha allagato s'è preso un
infarto dopo va bene basta incontrare
gente insomma basta voglio andare a casa
voglio andare a che voglio ritrovare
salve c'è un cervo ti seguo perché mi va
di seguirti no ragazzi cioè vi prego
visto che si sono studiati alla
perfezione di punti dove mettere il jump
square
mio dio posso andare nel lago senza che
nessuno mi mangi la faccia per fa volare
da come nota questo cos'è cos'è un
delfino esci dall'acqua che note stile
di nuoto è sta roba qua il coccige
trovato i pezzi sono 3 su serie devo
provare a tornare indietro senza che
nessuno mi ammazzi veloce ecco morto no
non sono morto sono quasi morto a
youtube sta trascinando nelle peggio
caverne aia che tesi stata ora sono
morto non sono morto mi ha portato e mi
ha trascinato in una caverna sotterranea
sono uscito non si sa come sotto natura
con che fisica sotto nato qua
impossibile o ragazzi sto svenendo
ma che cosa aiuto se no va bene a caso
ha cantanto guarda già al casinò ci
manca loro che venga a caso tipo dove
sono aiuto dove mi sono addormentato mi
hanno portato qua ma tu puoi essere così
stupido da addormentata ma come fai
essere mamma no ma dai ragazzi non ho
parole ve lo giuro ma puoi addormentarti
qualcosa è the forest che ti porta nelle
caverne aiuto sono un medico ho
sbagliato strada vi prego
porca vacca che è successo a po sfiorano
adesso si è fermato il personaggio
ottimo ace lo slider me ama potate di 1
subito a ma cavolo ci rincontriamo
maledetto malengo dove vi siano pietro
[Musica]
però non mi aspettavo di vedere sauron
non mi aspettavo
ok non sono al cavalcavia via via via
via via via sabato strada giorno c'è la
luce fuori vado corro non mi giro mamma
mia
ho sbagliato strada tantissimo e si work
a vacca mi stavo buttando da un
precipizio è ottimo sto bene tutto a
posto
ecco mi sembra definiamo e le cose no ok
mi ha fatto ripartire qua sono mi sono
suicidato volevo farlo è ferma da che
palle vieni qua salve guarda se rimane a
bocca ti seguivo così non ti seguo gli
spiace fi divertiti al suolo da che
parte devo andare qua anche di quel
casco mi sa che devo veramente tuffarmi
anch'io ma no dai ti prego non farmi
seguire sta roba dovuto farmi volta la
tavola volevo prepararmi al tuffo invece
cascata proprio giornata va la
fisicamente vabbè fages
non ci è successo vedo sfocato ho perso
gli occhiali se pagata l'acqua aspetta
ormai so anche come sbagliare i giochi
di andry dritto sì però devi trovarti un
posto in cui stare amico mio che poi
buongiorno amico mio non è che poi
andare in giro per la foresta per i
cavoli tuoi così è per favore mio dio
sono stato tagliola di fatto miscela
scritta salva ma non ho capito dove
fosse salvataggio automatico
solo che non sapevano tradurre in
italiano salvataggio automatico quindi
hanno scritto solo salva
buongiorno spero che sta a casa sia un
po più allegra di quella del marino se
più allegra
incontro dopo che il mona che sbatte le
porte qua aprile chi è chi è che il che
è che rompe le balle kill è stato li
mortacci sua no che è male
ho preso una nasata con la porta agli
usci nantes
ecco io non andrei lì sopra si è tolto
il lucchetto alla porta di no c'è del
fumo li quindi io andrei veramente qui
sotto
scherzavo scherzavo non scendiamo lì
sopra non ci andiamo ragazzi ragazzi
aprite la porta a prenderlo porta prima
porta si apre e uscire dalla fine alla
finestra finanziaria sia ecc e non si
esce lo stesso destino
sono morto
però c'è molto tempo e ceci che mi tuffo
che ansia di vivere mamma mia ragazzi
sto gioco incredibile eh vabbè pure i
tronchi quindi ragazzi questa è la prima
parte di the forest de courcelles
foreste gurs tra mix ai nomi dei giochi
potevi sempre piaciuto a me moltissime
molto stile horror vecchio purtroppo so
che non andrà tanto questo video perché
ormai horror sono passati un po di moda
però hanno sempre una parte nel mio
cuore quindi almeno un episodio dovevo
farlo poi magari mi sorprende va bene
quindi finisco la serie però è difficile
che gli horror oggi vadano sono molto
molto molto molto contento del fatto che
comunque siano stati gli horror a
problemi un po al successo mettiamola
così perché mi è sempre piaciuto farli è
tuttora a 24 anni mi diverto tantissimo
giocare agli operai vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi lasciato un bel mi piace
attivata la campanella qui sotto per
stagionati sono i video che escono come
sempre noi ci vediamo al prossimo video
per ragazzi
[Musica]